it's like it's gonna make myself laugh
[Applause]
we are here this looks like
McDowell's actually it does but it's not
it's not that other me go what is that
Mick Brett never heard of it they got
the golden arches - the golden arcs
we're gonna get the big Mick we're gonna
get the sexual chocolate shake and and
the moon the fried dough okay guess we
coming let's go let's do it so we have
returned from McDowell and our way up to
the tasting room so lorem was so excited
to see McDowell so she has joined us for
the taste test yes I love coming to
America it's like my favorite movie it's
not a real like representation of Africa
just so people know but I still love the
movie I mean we never see the menu items
we just hear about them in the movie all
we hear about is the big Mick right now
I'm really excited for this I'm excited
to try this um Linda fries so is this
the national dish of something that lets
you go yeah your royal french fries
often well here's my v it kind of looks
like McDonald's fries with cheese over
it but there are a lot of onions on
here's my breasts are you kickin later
I'm goin for it and I'm getting an
antacid that's perfect oh my god so this
is the big Mick oh no sesame seems it's
two all-beef patties special sauce
lettuce pickles cheese on a bun with no
sesame seeds clink why do you know the
eggs because I watched this movie at
least four times a year perhaps because
there are two are there french fries in
there I think so well that's okay no
listen this is a damn good sandwich this
makes me really want to go home and
watch this movie right now I'm sorry
that I've like not lived and not have
experienced coming to America before
what an actual [ __ ]
it has to weigh at least probably close
to two pounds
there's Hershey's Kisses because you
gotta start gentle this is what happens
after sexual track that is experienced
apparently you know I bet that is amiss
juices and berries this looks like
pudding
we tried McDowell's we tried McDowell's
oh my god is there traveling this is a
cool gonna pop up that they did I really
appreciate how they did it coming to
America is awesome if you haven't seen
it see it I'm embarrassed that I haven't
seen this movie still it was super fun
to walk into something that's like out
of linear all-time favorite movies I
really appreciated the the nostalgia of
it that they tried to replicate people
behind the counter wearing the exact you
know a little outfit I mean that movie
holds up thanking me down
[Music]
eighty-eight Wow this movie was made
before I was born
that's alluring